and like tom obviously being spider-man
you've got to be in amazing shape but
they did weird things to you i don't
know if you have uh what's the electric
thing have you ever heard of this ems
training
it's like a you wear this sort of like
black suit and they put these pads on
you and you basically do like a yoga
class while they electrocute you
and i it's like muscle stimulation yeah
it's like muscle stimulation but you
work out while you use it i basically
cheated um but i did it with my best
friend and every time the trainer would
go to the bathroom one of us would crank
up the machine that my friend was using
and you can't like you genuinely can't
move like it like makes every part of
your body shake and it's awful it's a
lot of fun and it works but it really is
the worst thing i've ever done i've
never heard of that that's yeah have you
no but i saw a commercial today on tv
here with cristiano ronaldo right who's
probably one of the most physical
specimens on the planet with this ab
machine and his bicep machine standing
there his underwear and he's just going
like this shaking with his eyes closed i
don't think that's how he got in shape
you know
somebody's sitting there on their couch
stuffing their face having a pint it's
gonna be like oh yeah well now i figured
it out i could
buy one of those it's not happening
[Music]